what's the story behind the unique
looking lightsaber everyone's after in
season two of the mandalorian
it's a key piece of mandalore's history
and has the power to both unite and
destroy the mandalorian people
here's everything you need to know about
the darksaber
as the mandalorian implies the jedi and
the mandalorians didn't always get along
well over a thousand years before the
rebel alliance and the empire
engaged in the galactic civil war the
warrior culture of the mandalorians
fought against the force users in a
conflict that ultimately ruined
mandalore's environment
forcing its people to live inside sealed
domes however
the two warring factions forged a
temporary truce when tarvisla
a force-sensitive mandalorian was
inducted into the jedi order
as per jedi tradition vizsla forged his
own lightsaber which had a black blade
with a white rim
that crackled with energy this weapon
became known as the darksaber and when
vizsla returned to mandalore
he used it to unite the warring clans
and become leader of the entire planet
the peace didn't last after vizsla died
the jedi honored him by placing the
darksaber in one of their temples
later hostilities broke out again as the
old republic fell
mandalorians invaded the jedi temple and
stole back the darksaber
taking it to mandalore where it became a
potent symbol of mandalorian power
in the clone wars series viewers were
introduced to an important wielder of
the darksaber
free vizla pre vizsla was one of
tarvisla's descendants
and the leader of both house vizsla and
death watch
a group of rebel mandalorians that
fought against the pacifist
new mandalorian government using the
darksaber to solidify his position as
the head of both groups
free vizsla teamed up with darth maul
and conquered mandalore in an attempt to
return the one-time warrior society
to its former glory here's the thing
about the darksaber not only does
holding it ensure that its wielder will
lead house vizsla
but there's only one way to claim it you
have to beat its former owner
in combat unfortunately that's exactly
what darth maul did
after the former sith lord helped
pre-vizsla conquer mandalore the
alliance between the two
fell apart maul challenged vizsla for
control of the darksaber and won
vissla died and with the darksaber in
hand maul became the new leader of house
vizsla
and accordingly the planet that was
simply too much for many mandalorians
who refused to bow to a non-mandalorian
overlord
some of isla's former supporters
including bocatan crees
switched sides fighting against maul's
forces
and helping the jedi and the republic
drive maul from the planet
maul didn't give up the weapon after his
defeat though he stashed it away on his
home planet
dathomir where it sat for the next 30
years
over time the republic became the empire
and mandalore once again fell under
fascist rule
however the darksaber saved it in star
wars rebels
a mandalorian exile named sabine wren
found the darksaber on
dathomir sabine learned how to use the
blade then took the dark saber to
mandalore to free her people
while some mandalorians initially
questioned sabine's claim to the
darksaber since she didn't defeat darth
maul to claim it
many including sabine's family rallied
behind sabine and the saber and rebelled
against their imperial overlords
with the dark saber in hand sabine
rescued her father from imperial
clutches
destroyed an imperial superweapon and
raised a small army
when the fighting was done sabine gave
the saber to bocatan crees
who used the darksaber's traditional
powers to reunite the mandalorians and
lead the planet to a new
if brief period of peace obviously the
darksaber doesn't look like a normal
lightsaber
its blade is shaped differently than its
regular counterparts
and its black and white color scheme is
unique in star wars lore
however as the star wars rebels episode
trials of the dark saber reveals
the weapon also has some unique
abilities that set it apart from the
more colorful lightsabers
all jedi have a personal relationship
with their lightsabers but the darksaber
takes it even further
while a kyber crystal focuses the
darksaber's energy
the blade is also controlled by its
wielders thoughts and emotions
which guide its power as a result the
darksaber seems to change
size and weight depending on who's
holding it and it crackles with
electricity when its wielder is excited
agitated or angry pre-vissla wasn't
always
going to wield the darksaber before the
mandalore arc of the clone wars
started production vizsla was going to
wield a vibroblade
a heated electrified metal sword except
george lucas didn't like that
as the clone wars rebels and mandalorian
executive producer dave filoni tells ign
lucas wasn't pleased that a
non-lightsaber weapon especially one
made out of metal
was blocking the jedi's iconic weapon
and so he changed it
rumors suggest that lucas went through a
few different iterations
including a rise of skywalker like
yellow lightsaber
before settling on the darksaber's final
design that's completely unsubstantiated
though so we'll never know for sure if
it's true
however thanks to felony we do know that
the darksaber is 100
a lucas creation the darksaber's
appearance in the mandalorian is the
weapon's live-action debut but the blade
almost appeared in a star wars movie a
year and a half earlier
when maul makes his surprise cameo at
the end of solo
a star wars story revealing that the
former sith apprentice is the power
behind the crimson dawn crime syndicate
he wields a double-bladed lightsaber
actor sam whitwer however had a
different idea
what if maul had carried the darksaber
instead while whitware wasn't involved
in the phantom menace
where maul first appeared he played the
character in the clone wars and rebels
and provided his voice in solo so when
whitware heard that maul would have a
lightsaber in solo he made sure to ask
which one
when he was told that maul was going to
be holding his phantom menace blade
widower pointed out that maul didn't
have that weapon anymore he either
needed to use his inquisitor blade or
the darksaber
ultimately solo's producers chose to use
the lightsaber maul having rebels not
the darksaber
since maul's best known for his double
blades
unsurprisingly the darksaber is a fairly
major part of the mandalorian season 2.
in the season's third episode the
heiress viewers meet bogatan
who saves mando from a watery grave and
helps him rescue grogu from being eaten
although she and the members of her
death watch are philosophically at odds
with mando they team up long enough to
raid an old imperial ship once on board
bokotan desperately grills the captain
for information about moff gideon's
whereabouts
insisting he has something that belongs
to her that's something the darksaber
after moff gideon steals grogu the
mandalorian assembles a crew to get him
back
and despite some fairly hairy moments he
does everything he sets out to do
starting with defeating moff gideon in
combat and taking the dark saber from
him
as it turns out this could be more
trouble than it was worth for mando when
he tries giving the weapon back to boca
ten a laughing gideon
points out that she can't take it the
only way a mandalorian can wield the
darksaber is if they best
its previous owner in combat bokutan
reluctantly admits he's right
which seemingly answers the question of
how gideon ended up with it in the first
place
by beating her in a fight how did
bogatan escape her initial battle with
moth gideon alive
and how will she and mando resolve
ownership of the darksaber now that he's
its rightful owner
these are just some of the many
questions waiting to be answered in the
mandalorian season 3.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars stories are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you